Speaker 1: . There's a clip of former Republican
Senator Rick Santorum making the rounds in
which he seems to either forget or pretend
not to remember that when Europeans came to
what is now the United States, there were
Native Americans here already.
There were societies and cultures and communities
already.
Rick Santorum is a really gross guy.
He's been a CNN contributor for some time
since he left the Senate.
Listen to what he had to say to the Young
America's Foundation about the United States
and its uniqueness.
If you think
Speaker 5: about this country, I don't know
of any other country in the world that was
settled.
Predominantly by people who are coming to
practice their faith.
They came here because they were not allowed
to practice their particular faith in their
own country, and so they came here mostly
from Europe.
And they set up a country.
That was based on Judeo-Christian principles,
I say Judeo-Christian, the Mosaic laws, Ten
Commandments and the teachings of Jesus Christ,
the moral and the moral and teachings of Jesus
Christ, that's that's what our founding documents
are based upon.
It's in our DNA, you know, if you think of
other countries like Italy and Greece and
China and Turkey and places like that, they've
all sort of.
Changed over time.
I mean, they've been they've been there for
scent for millennia in many cases, and their
culture has sort of evolved over time.
But not us.
We came here and created a blank slate, we
we birthed a nation from nothing.
I mean, there nothing here.
I mean, yes, we have Native Americans, but
but candidly, that that there isn't much Native
American culture in American culture.
Speaker 1: So there is a lot there and we
will get into it.
But what I was struck by in watching the clip
is how so much of what these right wingers
consider their values and principles are based
on faulty understandings of history, where
their logic is often functioning in reverse.
I'll give you an example.
Rick Santorum says there isn't much Native
American culture in American culture.
He says that to defend his claim that there
really wasn't anything here when Europeans
came to what is now the United States and
had what was here when they arrived been more
valuable, we would still see much more Native
American cultural influence today.
It's completely backwards reasoning.
There isn't much Native American culture today
because Native Americans were widely exterminated,
their land taken, and we simply destroyed
their culture and overran it.
His reasoning is the fact that not much of
their culture is left is evidence that there
wasn't much interesting about it when in fact,
the reason there isn't much left is American
settlers decided to get rid of it.
But it's a pretty grim insight into how Rick
Santorum views the people that were here when
European settlers arrived, which is there
wasn't much of value to him based on his values,
which are the Judeo-Christian stuff that he
said about the founding of the United States
of America.
The truth is there was culture, there was
infrastructure, there were communities, there
were customs.
None of it was of any value to people like
Rick Santorum.
Now, if you're interested in learning more
about this, the book, Fourteen Ninety One
gives you a real sense of the Americas before
European settlers landed.
But there's this kind of interplay between
Rick Santorum's religious beliefs serving
as a justification for what happened here
and what happened here then becomes a justification
for his religious views.
It's this closed loop that can't be broken.
Doc says the closure is the term I've used
in the past to describe it.
And then we get to the bigger picture message,
which is this is just another example of how
these right wingers are incredibly staunch
in their beliefs because they think they know
what those beliefs are based on.
But it turns out their beliefs are based on
misunderstandings and errors.
It's you know, I've talked I've jokingly talked
before about what's the next principled stance
Ted Cruz will take based on something he misheard
or misunderstood.
This is a really tough cycle to break because
first you have to look at their premises and
take them down one by one.
Actually, there were communities and cultures
and tons of things here.
Actually, we are responsible for getting rid
of those things.
And so actually the situation of the US is
getting to where it is today isn't that unique?
And it's certainly not particularly heroic.
It has a lot of ugly in the past and it has
a ton of innovation.
Of course, this applies to a lot of the modern
right wing set of beliefs.
Taxes are bad for the economy and so Democrats
are bad for wanting higher taxes.
And so the economy also will do poorly under
Democrats.
Whoa, hold on a second.
Actually, well calibrated and well balanced
taxation is good for the country.
The stock market has done better under Democrats.
It's a lot of work, as many of you know, who
have tried to convince, you know, you're crazy
right wing uncle at Thanksgiving.
It's a lot of work to get people to change
their minds on these things.
And, of course, this particular example for
Rick Santorum also has him.
It's all kind of draped in his religious beliefs,
both to justify his religious beliefs and
to glorify them.
And this is what they do unless we tell people
otherwise and even when we tell people otherwise,
often they keep doing it anyway.
So this this is tough.
I've not found the solution on this.
We've spoken to social psychologist.
We've spoken to so many different people.
About changing minds and when it's this deep,
it is very difficult and we're going to see
really a horrifying example of this after
the next thing or after the next segment in
the last segment of the show, a really horrible
example of this from Tucker Carlson unmasking.
So that's later.
Make sure you're following us on Instagram
for more on this story.
We are on Instagram at David Pakman show.
You can find me on Instagram at David Pakman